in this era of climate change the great
mountains and forests of the american
west are now conjuring images of huge
wildfires and crippling droughts we've
seen that but that should never
overshadow the sublime beauty i love the
word sublime sublime beauty and grandeur
that is lured people since well before
the founding of our country cbs senior
environmental correspondent that's been
tracy went to the rocky mountains of
colorado to contemplate what's at stake
as our planet warms and what we can
still save
there is a reason the rocky mountains
are so often described as majestic their
jagged peaks forming cathedrals in the
sky
deferring only to the sun and clouds
above
john muir the father of our national
park system once said going to the
mountains
is like going home
of course this was home to the native
people and they're the ones that gave
these mountains their name because from
across the prairie they said these
looked like distinctive rocks
[Music]
the rocky mountains stretch for more
than 3 000 miles through six states its
spine so tough it divides a continent
sending rivers flowing to oceans in two
directions
[Music]
unprecedented wildfires fueled by
climate change are ravaging the rockies
scientists say the forests here are
burning more than at any point in the
past 2000 years
three of the largest recorded wildfires
in colorado's history all took place in
2020
charring hundreds of thousands of acres
the summers here are now hotter than
they used to be in the winter there's
less snow it's making everything here a
whole lot drier that's making the fires
more destructive
in a new study scientists say if the
fires here continue at this pace
every forest in this region could be
burned by the end of this century
[Music]
of course the rockies were formed by
adversity raised by the shifting earth
and carved by glaciers they have stood
for tens of millions of years
john muir liked to think of the
mountains as home which is why he also
said the mountains are calling and i
must go
but if he were alive today he might be
surprised by what he finds when he gets
here
for cbs mornings then tracy in the rocky
mountains of colorado
thank you ben tracy we're going to do
more stories like that just to keep
reminding people what's at stake and how
important this is that nature is out
there yeah for sure i'm a seattle god i
consider myself a city slicker but i
went to nevada arena and being in some
remote areas of nevada i realized how
much of this earth in nature that we
need to protect and i didn't really get
that message till i was 19 20 years old
so i'm glad that we're doing stories
like this because we need to hear this
at a younger age yeah well for a long
time people thought like oh we're just
little people we can't hurt the big
planet but yeah it turns out we can
seems like we're consuming it i'm
thinking being a city slicker is a good
thing huh yeah
look at your city slicker
city's liquor he's a city slicker all
right